hey this is pressure Walker reminding
you to mind your decisions start out
with a line segment and draw a
semicircle
now extend this line segment and draw
another semicircle now along this entire
line segments draw another semicircle
suppose a B has a length of 10 now focus
on just the green curve and the blue
curve how does the length of the blue
curve compare to the length of the green
curve it's a multiple choice question a
the green curve is longer be the blue
curve is longer see the curves have
equal length and D the relationship
cannot be determined from the given
information this problem is adapted from
SAT and GRE problems and it said that
many people miss this kind of problem
can you figure it out give this problem
a try and when you're ready keep
watching the video for a solution so how
can we solve this problem let's
calculate the length of each curve first
let's calculate the length of the green
curve recall that the circumference of a
circle is equal to its diameter times pi
the green curve will be half of the
circumference of a circle with the
diameter of 10 this means the length of
the green curve is half of 10 pi which
is equal to 5 pi will now calculate the
length of the blue curve the blue curve
consists of two different semi circles
let's label one diameter as X which
means the other will be 10 minus X
because a B is equal to 10 the length of
the blue curve is equal to 1/2 the
circumference of a circle with the
diameter of X and half the circumference
of a circle with the diameter of 10
minus X we substitute in those values
and then simplify notice the 0.5 pi X
terms cancel out so the length of the
blue curve is equal to five pi and now
we can answer the question both of the
curves have exactly the same length of
five pi and it's true regardless of the
value of X
so the answer is see the curves have
equal length
thanks for watching these math videos
available for free on youtube build
confidence for students and inspire
mathematical discovery for viewers
around the world
they have over 800 million views and the
channel has over 1 million subscribers
please subscribe for free to give the
newest videos and email me a puzzle or
map topic pressure and mind your
decisions calm if you so choose you can
check out my merchandise on teespring
you can check out my books listed in the
video description and you can support me
on patreon thanks for watching and
thanks for your support